we have had a pandemic on this planet
with a few million people dead which we
will which we may never know whether or
not it was a lab leak because there was
definitely cover-up we don't know that
if there was a lab leak but we know that
the people who did the research like you
know like put out the whole paper about
this definitely wasn't a lab leak and
didn't reveal that they had been doing
had like sent off Corona Fire
coronavirus research to the Wuhan
Institute of virology after it was
banned in the United States after the
gain of function research was
temporarily banned in the United States
and
the same people who exported a gain of
function research on coronaviruses to
the woonhan Institute of virology after
it began to function that game event
gain of function research was
temporarily banned in the United States
are now getting more grants
to do more research on a gain of
function research on coronaviruses
maybe we do better in this than in AI
but like this is not something we cannot
take for granted that there's going to
be an outcry
yeah people have different thresholds
for when they start to outcry
but I I think your intuition is that
there's a very high probability that
this event happens without us solving
the alignment problem and I guess that's
where I'm trying to
build up more uh perspectives and color
on the situation is it possible that the
probability is not something like 100
but it's like 32 percent
that uh AI will escape the Box before we
solve the alignment problem not solve
but is it possible we always stay ahead
of the AI in terms of our ability to
solve for that particular system the
alignment problem nothing like the world
in front of us right now
you've already seen it that that that
gpt4 is not turning out this way
and there are like basic obstacles where
you've got the the weak version of the
system that doesn't know enough to
deceive you and the strong version of
the system that could to see if it
wanted to do that if it was already like
sufficiently unaligned to want to
deceive you there's the question of like
how on the current Paradigm you train
honesty when the humans can no longer
tell if the system is being honest
you don't think these are research
questions that could be answered I think
they could be the answer to 50 years
with unlimited retries the way things
usually work in science
I just disagree with that you're making
it 50 years I think with the kind of
attention this gets with kind of funding
and guess that could be answered uh not
in whole but in incrementally within
within months and within a small number
of years if it's a if it's at scale
receives attention and research so if
you start studying large language models
I think there was an intuition like two
years ago even that something like gpt4
the current capabilities of even Chad
GPT with GPT 3.5 is not is gonna we're
still far away from that I think a lot
of people are surprised by the
capabilities of gpt4 right so now people
are waking up okay we need to study
these language models I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting AI
Safety Research are the are Earth's
billionaires going to put up like the
the giant prizes that would maybe
incentivize young hot shot people who
just got their physics degrees to not go
to the hedge funds and instead put
everything into interpretability in this
like one small area where we can
actually tell whether or not somebody
has made a discovery or not I think so
because uh
well that's what these these
conversations are about because they're
going to wake up to the fact that gpt4
can be used to manipulate elections to
influence geopolitics to influence the
economy there's a lot of there's going
to be a huge amount of incentive to like
wait a minute we can't this has to be we
have to put we have to make sure they're
not doing damage we have to make sure we
interpretability we have to make sure we
don't understand how these systems
function so that we can predict their
effect on economy so that there's uh so
there's a feudal moral fairness and a
bunch of op-eds in the New York Times
and nobody actually stepping forth and
saying you know what instead of a mega
yacht I'd rather put that billion
dollars on prizes for young Hotshot
physicists who make fundamental
breakthroughs and interpretability
the yacht versus the interpretability
research the old uh the old trade-off uh
I I just I think uh it's just I think
there's going to be a huge amount of
allocation of funds I hope I guess you
want to bet me on that
well you want to put a time scale on it
say how much funds you think are going
to be allocated in a direction that I
would consider to be actually useful
by what time
I do think there will be a huge amount
of funds
but you're saying it needs to be open
right the development of the system
should be closed but the development of
the the interpretability research the
Aisa we are so far behind on inter under
under interpretability compared to
capabilities like yeah you could you
could take the last generation of
systems the the stuff that's already in
the open there is so much in there that
we don't understand there are so many
prizes you could do before you you know
you could you could you would have
enough insights that you'd be like oh
you know like well we understand how
these systems work we understand how
these things are doing their outputs we
can read their minds now let's try it
with the bigger systems yeah we're
nowhere near that there's so much
interpretability work to be done on the
weaker versions of the systems